well it's already happened with some
charter schools catholic schools private
schools could the end of distance
education finally be coming to the clark
county school district
the board of trustees plan to talk about
transitioning from remote learning at
home
to a hybrid plan tomorrow at their
meeting a news now reporter kristen
drummond shows us the considerations
the ccsd board meeting is only a
discussion no vote will be taken on
transitioning from distance education
to an in-person hybrid plan but families
tell me
this is at least a start it's just not
working well celeste tran wants her
five-year-old son laquan
back in school he loves to like be in
person and interact with people so
i feel like he needs that needs she says
the kindergartner cannot meet with
remote learning
it's definitely a struggle because he
has an iep
tran welcomes trustees discussing
community feedback for a safe
in-person hybrid plan during the
thursday meeting the first step in
possibly returning teachers and students
to the classroom
we've received an absolute avalanche
of input trustee linda cavazo
says the meeting needs to focus on
various factors not only the coveted
numbers but
resources for reopening do we have
enough special needs teachers that are
willing to come back into the classroom
cavazos knows mental health challenges
continue for students but
she does not want to create a worse
situation by reopening schools too
soon are we going to put children
and staff in a position
where it's only going to be for a short
time and then we have to
upend them again kovit's not going to go
away trans outlook as she waits to see
what trustees do next it's not going to
ever be what they expect
the board will vote on a hybrid
transition plan at the november 12th
meeting
reporting in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now kristin thank you
the southern nevada health district will
provide trustees with the very latest
covid numbers a report from the agenda
also shows there is still a higher risk
of transmission in schools based on data
as of this monday